الينا من جناب العقيد الكسندر بوتفافير
رئيسه تحرير المجله العسكريه السويسريه
اهلا بك سيد
بدايه كيف يمكن قراءه العلاقه الحاليه بين
موسكو وشركه فاجنر في ضوء هذه التهديدات
التي اطلقتها الشركه بالانسحاب من بخموت
من الصعب فعلا ان نشرح هذه العلاقه انها
علاقه شائكه لانه بموجب القانون الروسي
فان مجموعه مسلحه مثل فاجنر لا يجب ان
تكون تتمتع باي مشروعيه او مصداقيه في
روسيا
وبالتالي هي موجوده لانها تخدم مصالح بعض
الاشخاص والاطراف داخل النظام الروسي
وكانت مفيده لان مستوى التحفيز والكفاءات
في الجيش الروسي بدا يتراجع واتت فاغنر او
المجموعه او المؤسسات
جبل عسكريه والميشويه وغيرها لكي تكمل
ينقص الجيش الروسي والقوات الروسيه هي
كذلك تخدم مصالح موسكو بمحاربه اوكرانيا
كيف نفسر هذا الجدل في خضم المعارك المستم
الامر سهل جدا فالوضع لا يسري بطريقه جيده
جدا بالنسبه لروسيا الان ونرى
منظمات مختلفه واطرفا مختلفه داخل الجيش
وكلها وفي القطاع العسكري كلها تتنافس على
الموارد ضمن الاطار المؤسساتي الروسيه
وبالتالي بين القوات البريه القوات
المظليه
والقوات الجويه ووحدات اخرى هناك الكثير
من الاحتكاك هناك الكثير من التوتر والامر
يزداد سوءا حين تاتي شركات عسكريه خاصه
مثل لافاكنر وهل يخدم هذا الوضع برايك
اوكرانيا الان
انا واثق من انه سوف يكون من الصعب على
اوكرانيا ان تستفيد استفاده مباشره من ذلك
لان فاغنر قد تعهدت بعدد كبيره تحدث عن
عشرات الالاف من الجنود والقوات ومن غير
المرجح
ان تقوم فاغنر باداره ظهرها والانسحاب من
العمليات الروسيه العسكريه لكن طبعا هذا
يظهر التوترات والاحتكاكات داخل الجيش
الروسي حتى رئيس الاوكراني كان لديه تصريح
لافت عندما قال بانه سيشن الهجوم المضاد
دون انتظار وصول الطائرات الحربيه من
الغرب ما الذي يمكن ان نفهمه من كلام
زيلنسكي
هناك الكثير من الضغوطات على اوكرانيا من
اجل ان تظهر انها فعلا تربح تنتصر تحقق
انجازا معينه
من اجل ان تظهر للدول الغربيه انها فعلا
تستخدم المعدات العسكريه التي زودتها بها
وانها تنتصر في هذا الحرب وانه هناك فرصه
بانها سوف تفوز بها اذا هذه الضغوطات
تتزايد بالنظر الى الوضع صعب الذي تجد
القوات الاوكرانيه نفسها فيه هي موجوده
الان في باخ موت وبالتالي من الضروري ان
تحصل هذه الهجمه المضاده قبل ان تخسر ضخمه
لصالح القوات الروسيه وبرايك الامور الى
اين تتجه لا سيما في بخموت
ان لم تحصل هذه العمليه المضاده على نطاق
واسع وهذا ما تحدثنا عنه
فعل الارجاح في الايام او الاسابيع
القليله المقبله سنرى ان القوات
الاوكرانيه
سوف لن تتمكن من السيطره على باخ موتو
وبالتالي لن يعود منطقيا الاستمرار في
القتال داخل المدينه ويكون من الاجنبها ان
تستثمر تستثمر مواردها في القتال في مكان
اخر اشكرك جزيل الشكر السيد
الكافير من جنيف وانت رئيس تحرير المجله
العسكريه السويسريه